I'm working on a little project right
now, and I need your help. All the
details are on a YouTube post I'm
linking, but basically I'm building a
deck around an unknown event card
created for me using feedback from both
my in-person opponents and my online
audience. If you want to suggest cards
that could go in the deck, you can do
that under the YouTube post. And if you
want to guarantee an on color card going
in the deck, you can send it to my PO
box, address in the description. With
that said, let's get to the topic of
your horrible pet cards. Let's say you
have a type of card that you want to see
in a lot of games with a given deck. A
mana rock, a one mana creature that
gains life, or something else. If that's
the case, it can be helpful to run some
calculations on how often you'll draw
it, either by using a hyper geometric
calculator like the one on my website,
or by referencing the built-in
calculators that a deck building website
like Architect might have. At this
point, a lot of players are aware of
these sorts of tools, but what they
might not be aware of is that you can do
the opposite. You can check how often
you won't draw cards you don't want. And
just as you could use this to decide how
many of a desirable card you could do
the same deciding how few of an
undesirable card type to add. Because it
might actually be okay to have some bad
cards in your deck. But hold on, let's
take a step back here. What do I mean
when I say bad card, and why would I
want to run any of these? Starting with
that first question, the card we're
talking about could truly be a bad card.
My Radha Heir to Keld deck has a single
permanent funny seven drop deck slot. It
was occupied by Panglacial Wurm in the
past, and it's currently occupied by
Tyrant of Discord, with both of these
being not very good creatures. However,
the meaning of bad card could also be a
bit more complicated, being a card that
is either situational or bad without
certain other cards to support it. As
one example, in three different grindy
decks I play, there's a card present
that is there entirely for the purpose
of life gain. These cards are pretty
worthless outside of this task, but they
do an admirable job in a mid-to-late
game situation where my life total is in
a state of peril. As another example, in
my bracket two deck, I run a couple
artifact creatures that untap things.
These cards on their own are terrible,
but paired with other cards, they can be
pretty powerful. And Voltaic Construct
is technically part of a convoluted
infinite combo the deck can assemble. As
a final example, protection spells fit
both of these criteria as cards that
aren't useful until you're doing
something worth protecting, and whose
usefulness isn't realized until an
opponent tries to disrupt you.
So, this is what I mean when I say bad
cards. Cards that frequently don't feel
very good to draw for one reason or
another, particularly in the early game.
But, why does the category I'm
constructing treat these different types
of cards as the same? And if they're bad
in some sense, then why run them in the
first place?
The answer is that I think of a lot of
Commander decks as having two very
distinct phases, pre-engine and
post-engine.
In the early phases of a game, you only
have access to a very small number of
cards, and a lot of decks gain access to
additional cards through the synergies
between these early cards. This could
take a lot of different forms. Maybe you
have a Wall of Omens and a Teleportation
Circle. Maybe you follow up your Caustic
Bronco with an Ishin. Maybe you curve
Thran Dynamo into a Pull from Tomorrow.
Maybe you just play a standalone draw
engine like an Esper Sentinel or a
Phyrexian Arena, or even a series of
one-off spells like Night's Whisper and
Harmonize. Regardless, you're using
stuff from your more limited early game
card pool to help your deck reach a
state where it's online and has access
to a much wider range of the different
tools within it. And there are actually
a lot of things that can help with this.
Card draw, tutors, filtering, ramp,
synergy pieces that assist with any of
those last four things. All of these can
help you build up to a point where you
have access to a greater amount of your
library. Removal and defensive cards can
also help with this, since they buy you
the time to get that engine up and
going. Different cards will help
different amounts with this, but quite a
lot of cards will assist at least a
little bit. All of this is well and
good, but you might still be wondering
why exactly I'm drawing this pre-engine
and post-engine distinction. The answer
is that once you're cycling through a
more significant amount of your deck per
turn, whether or not each individual
card is useful in a wide variety of
situations starts to become a lot less
important. If I draw five cards and one
of them isn't that useful to me right
now, that's okay. I still drew four
other cards. This is also the point of
the game where you're going to start
discarding to hand size if you don't
have a Reliquary Tower effect. And this
is one of my favorite points in the game
to be in. Getting to purge the trash for
the first time in a game and sculpt a
hand of seven beautiful, situationally
applicable cards, delicious. As a slight
tangent, this sort of reasoning is also
why I like a type of budget dual land
that a lot of other people seem to
dislike, the humble fast land. A land
that enters tapped if you control three
or more other lands might seem kind of
bad in theory. In the average bracket
three Commander game, you're hopefully
making at least seven land drops. So, in
less than half of land drops will this
land enter untapped. However, turn four
and beyond is also a point in the game
at which a lot of decks will be drawing
or looting or otherwise filtering,
enabling them to find their way to a
variety of different lands with relative
ease. The first three turns of the game
are the ones where you're going to be
the hardest pressed to have a land that
both enters untapped and gives the
colors you need. And fast lands fill
this exact profile. So, if your deck is
one that rounds a corner and starts to
see a lot more cardboard at some point,
having a somewhat subpar or situational
card is a lot less of a problem from
that point onward. But, what does this
mean for the early game? Well, as I
suggested earlier, you can do a bit of
math to see how likely it is for your
game plan to get online.
One option here is to separate your
non-land cards into three buckets.
Bucket one is high-quality drawn
filtering, stuff that finds you to what
you need to succeed quickly and easily.
Bucket two is stuff that's basically
useless for getting your deck online,
hyper-situational cards, protection
spells, later game tech pieces,
finishers, and stuff that's just kind of
bad that you include them for shits and
giggles, as is your god-given right.
Bucket three is all the other stuff
outside of these two categories. Ramp,
removal, somewhat narrower draw, and
sometimes applicable tech pieces. Now,
you perform two different checks here.
For one, how likely is it for you to
draw one of your bucket one cards, your
premium quality enablers? The larger
this number is, the better. But, there
are certainly reasons why this number
could be lower for some decks.
Question two is how likely it is for you
to draw one of your bucket two cards
that helps you very little in the early
game. And possibly more importantly, how
likely is it for you to draw multiple of
these? If you're running five or so
hyper-situational cards, the odds of
drawing more than one of these is quite
low. By contrast, if that number starts
creeping up into the double digits, you
might have games where you draw an
overwhelming stampede and a heroic
intervention in your first 10 cards of
the game, a fervor and a full throttle,
a clever concealment and a storm herd.
You can almost think about all of these
bucket two bad cards as blank for the
purposes of your early game. Having a
lot of these is generally going to slow
your timeline for getting off the ground
and lead to more stall outs. But, you
can counter balance these tendencies
with a greater amount of bucket one
cards, high quality draw and filtering.
Hitting a string of situational cards
you won't want until later in the game
can be a problem, but it might not be if
you have a lot of filtering and draw and
tutors at the ready to cut you through
this dead
So, how much janky nonsense is it okay
to put in your deck? I mean, don't let
me stop you from living your best life,
especially if you're in more bracket two
territory, but the realistic answer is
that it depends on what the rest of your
deck is doing. If we're talking about
some terrible pet cards that you would
literally die for, take a look at how
many other cards you're running that
you'd be kind of bummed to draw before
turn five. If that number is very low,
you're probably okay to add some garbage
to your deck. Treat this as your reward
for being such a responsible deck
builder in other ways. If that number is
stretching into double digits territory,
you'll want to be a bit more careful.
How much general purpose draw and
filtering are you running? How broadly
useful is your commander for generating
resources and helping your deck get
going? My deck with the highest number
of bucket two cards is my Meria of
Ultron deck with a ton of protection as
well as equipments to give extra damage
and evasion. With any other commander,
this deck's ratios would make no sense
at all and it would flail around doing
nothing most of the time. However,
because Meria is a sweet draw engine and
one of the best mana producers in the
game, and because my deck is pretty
decent at protecting her, it ends up
working out most of the time. Likewise,
it's not a coincidence that my one
bracket three deck where I allow myself
to indulge in significantly more janky
pet cards is also one where I have a
mana dork commander and a massive pile
of four cost ramp spells and six to
seven cost bombs that I'm pretty much
always happy to draw. Craft the
foundation of your deck in a way that's
maximally consistent and flexible and
the amount of room to sprinkle garbage
into that bad boy might just surprise
you.
Thanks for watching. Make sure to check
out the YouTube post in the description
if you want to contribute to that. And
another thing you can check out is
fantastic products from Dragon Shield.
I'm a long time enjoyer of their dual
matte sleeves with my Radha deck still
going strong in the same set of peach
sleeves thousands of shuffles in.
Sleeves that have been used that heavily
have a really interesting shuffle feel
to them, but that's not something you'll
ever get to experience with most other
brands. Dragon Shield has also been
expanding out into deck boxes and other
storage methods which I'm also a fan of.
The deck boxes are elegant and
effective. Get 5% off your order at the
link in the description and you'll be
helping the channel in the process. If
you want to support the channel more
directly, you can sign up for my Patreon
or a YouTube membership. I'm in the
process of moving right now which is
exciting in some ways, but also
expensive. So, any extra dough to throw
at gas and Craigslist furniture is much
appreciated. A big thanks to my current
patrons and YouTube members for their
ongoing support.